Star Trek is one of the jewels in the
crown over at parot it is one of the
franchises that has the most value they
want to fully control that value and
they want to be able to make it sellable
but we didn't know about this merger
idea and all of a sudden this idea of
Star Trek Studios makes a little bit
more sense in another way you create a
basically a separate company it's a
subsidary of parmount global and then
when you're talking to Warner Brothers
about the merger Star Trek Studios
suddenly becomes a separate entity it's
another piece on the chessboard will it
go with CBS or will it go with Paramount
this will not be a repeat of what we had
before when CBS and Paramount separated
when Paramount owned the movie rights to
Star Trek but CBS owned the TV rights
and we got JJ Abram Star Trek out of
it there will be one entity that owns
both and it will be Star Trek Studios